(audience clapping and cheering)
- All right y'all, it's time to close out
with something we found on social media.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
If you're an animal lover like me,
chances are you will do almost anything
to make your fur baby feel
like part of the family.
My next guest took that to
a whole new level people,
they're Chicago mixologists
who created a high-end crafted cocktail
for their cat, Mr. Biscuits,
non-alcoholic, of course.
(whimsical music)
- Hi, I know it's time for your cocktail.
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Snuggle city.
Instagram exploded over this video.
Here's my favorite comment though.
Word to the wise, I tried this with my cat
and found him in the corner on the phone
swiping right on every
kitten in a five mile radius.
(audience laughing and clapping)
Yeah, alcohol goggles.
We have Jess, John, and Mr. Biscuits
on the line right now
watching on NBC Chicago.
What's up y'all?
(audience clapping and cheering)
- Hi Kelly.
- Oh my gosh, your cat is so cute.
So how did your cat learn to like this
or did like the cat like the
cocktails right off the bat?
- Yeah, so Kelly, we're big
cocktail people in our house.
John and I actually own a
small business here in Chicago
called Aged and Infused.
So we make a line of all
natural alcohol infusion kits.
So we're always drinking
good come happy hour.
And a few months ago, we
were sipping on our martinis
and looked over at this little
three-legged flooffy cat,
Mr. Biscuits, and we were like,
we gotta get him in on the action.
So we went thrifting,
found the tiniest martini
glass we could find,
and then John came up with
a little cocktail recipe.
- Yeah, I took his favorite treat,
which is this disgusting salmon paste
and add a little water
to it, shaken over ice.
And he absolutely loves it.
- Oh my gosh, I wish I
weren't allergic to cats
'cause I would fly to your house
and I would just snuggle
with Mr. Biscuits.
I'm mean that fur, I wanna
bury my face in that fur.
Oh my gosh.
Well, so do you have
some new recipes, right?
- [Jess] Oh yeah.
- Yeah, I've been playing
around with a little bit
of tuna juice and then we
garnish it with a little bit
of catnip and he absolutely
loses his mind over it.
We call it the cat-opolitan.
- And these cat lovers are no joke.
People are asking for more recipes.
They wanna know where we got
the little shaker and glasses from.
So we're actually working on a
little kitty cat cocktail kit
that we're gonna sell with our business
so people can make
cocktails for their cats.
- I was gonna say that.
I was like, you are missing a
giant opportunity here, man.
I was like,
- We got this.
- That's amazing, can
you imagine a kitty bar?
Anyway, it sounds fun and I
wanna do one of the voices.
Anyway, thank you so much Jess and John.
I'm liking your post right now,
but that's not all, our season
long partner Pilot pen makers
of G2 and the new G2 Edge, the go-to pens
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
love that you are giving Mr. Biscuits
the time of his life really.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand thousand dollars.
That should help with some recipes.
(audience clapping and cheering)
All the catnip.
Thank you guys so much.
I love your family.
Thank you to all our guests this hour,
Bryce Dallas Howard, Catherine O'Hara,
Desmond Meade, Frank, Angel, and Whitney.
Y'all have a great day and
if it's not, change it.
(audience clapping and cheering)
(upbeat music)